when ingo swann released his book titled
penetration in 1998 he claimed to be a
psychic who was employed by the cia to
remote view the dark side of the moon
specifically to look for alien presence
it sounded like science fiction but in
2006 when the cia started releasing
documents on the stargate project
swann's participation in the program was
confirmed when swann was asked about the
existence of extraterrestrials he said
not only were they already here but they
are building something on the far side
of the moon and according to swan these
aliens
aren't friendly let's find out why
[Music]
when ingo's swamp was a child his family
noticed he had psychic potential when he
got older he wanted to explore this
talent so he began volunteering for
experiments in esp at first researchers
tested swan to see if he could influence
plants with mental activity or alter the
temperature of an environment using his
mind and swan was successful enough that
more and more scientists became
interested in him but it was a few years
later where ingo swann would find his
specialty in the early 1970s swan was
part of a study for the american society
of psychical research and this study
involved swan sitting in a chair and
attempting to project his consciousness
into sealed boxes which contained
symbols that swam would try to read
during one experiment he was asked to
see what he saw inside of a box and swan
said he saw nothing just darkness the
researcher was disappointed and said oh
that's too bad let's try something else
swann said no i see darkness because the
light bulb inside the box is burnt out
the researcher was puzzled he walked
over to the box opened it and sure
enough the light was out and a star was
born
[Music]
ingoswan's success in these early
experiments got the attention of the
stanford research institute you might
remember the sri from our project
stargate video which i'll link below sri
had been remote viewing places around
the world for years but once they found
ingo swan who was extremely successful
at this they wondered if he could remote
view other places in the solar system
there was an experiment in 1973 where
ingo swann was asked to project his
consciousness to the planet jupiter at
first swan rejected the idea ingo swan
never wanted to remote view anything
that couldn't be confirmed there are
plenty of frauds who claim to have
psychic abilities and swan valued his
reputation he didn't see any value in
going to jupiter if his observations
couldn't be confirmed but the
researchers at sri told swan jupiter was
chosen because nasa had probes on the
way there right now so swann agreed and
he made a lot of observations about
jupiter that the pioneer probes soon
confirmed he saw a hydrogen mantle
rotating storms like cyclones he
mentioned high infrared readings the
colors of the clouds and ice crystals in
the atmosphere the probes confirmed all
of this they did skeptics will say all
these observations could be deduced like
of course jupiter has violent storms we
can see them same with the color of
clouds infrared and atmospheric ice
crystals even if we can't see this stuff
we can deduce that they're there but
swan saw something else something new
he said he saw a ring around jupiter
just like saturn's ring but jupiter's
ring according to swan was much smaller
than saturn's and closer to the planet
he said it was made up of dust and tiny
asteroids this was not something we
could see from earth or even assume was
there did the probe see the ring
the pioneer probes in 1973 and 1974 did
not see a faint ring around jupiter
but when voyager 1 passed by jupiter in
1979 tell me there was a ring
there was a ring
[Music]
i am not this body
in terms of consciousness and
consciousness can go places where the
body cannot
ingo's swam was so accurate as a remote
viewer that people began to take notice
specifically the united states
government of course in march 1975 ingo
swann received a call at three in the
morning he was told to go to washington
and visit the museum of natural history
there he should stand near the elephant
in the central rotunda at noon so he
does right on schedule a
military-looking man approaches him and
hands him a card it reads do not speak
or ask questions this is for our safety
as well as yours please follow me he's
led to a car and seated next to another
military-looking man and in his book he
calls these guys the twins and twin
number two hands him another card it
reads please do not speak we need to
search you for listening devices they do
and he's handed one final card we would
like your help on a project suited to
your talent are you comfortable in a
helicopter
well swann takes a long moment finally
nods the twins take the cards from ingo
swan's hand then a bag is placed over
his head
and the car speeds away
though ingo's swan couldn't see he felt
that he was driven around in circles
eventually he's led from the car where
he hears a helicopter spinning up his
face still shrouded he's buckled in and
flown to a location in or near
washington dc when the helicopter lands
swan is led to a quiet building and then
into an elevator the doors open and the
bag is finally removed swan blinks his
eyes adjusting to the light then a
kindly looking man introduces himself as
mr axelrod ingo swann is obviously
nervous and mr axelrod sees this he
smiles tells him not to worry that he's
in no danger and offers him a cigar swan
gladly takes one it's his brand the men
go to an office sit and enjoy a cigar
where mr axelrod makes a proposal
axelrod says he represents a group who
would like swan to participate in a
remote viewing project for his effort he
would be paid one thousand dollars a day
in cash which in today's money is over
six thousand dollars a day inflation huh
yup are we gonna talk about the federal
reserve and what a scam it is uh not in
this video
okay settle down so ingoswan really
needs the money but to get it there are
a few catches first he can't reveal any
of this to anyone and can't speak of it
for at least 10 years
the other catch is for the next few days
swan isn't to leave the facility he'll
be provided with a comfortable room tv a
gym swimming pool and anything he needs
but if he takes the job he stays on site
under constant surveillance now ingo
swann is quiet for a while as crazy as
the past few years have been he's never
been through anything like this
mysterious calls in the middle of the
night clandestine meetings subterranean
facilities and now a kind but strange
man offers him a lot of cash for an
unknown mission axelrod sees swan
processing all of this and finally asks
if he agrees to the terms swan nods that
he does axelrod puts out his cigar
shakes swan's hand and says good get
some rest tomorrow we begin
[Music]
and it has very distinct features of a
satellite dish it's got the dish itself
the crater shape it's got a long spike
that appears to come out of the middle
all sorts of stuff that looks exactly
like a satellite dish on earth looks
[Music]
the next morning axelrod tells ingo swan
that he'll be remote viewing the moon
and swan is confused by this but axelrod
reminds him no questions right and swan
is given a list of coordinates and goes
through them one by one some locations
he doesn't see anything but others he
was able to view large cliffs see
craters dunes of white powder all the
things you'd expect to see on the moon
finally swan comes across something
interesting and confusing he describes
seeing tracks on the surface tracks that
seem to have been made by tractors or
some kind of machinery he sees patterns
that look like they were made by wind
even though the moon has no atmosphere
supposedly supposedly swan gets the
sense that there is atmosphere there
then swan moves into a crater which is
filled with a green haze something is
generating light and swan notes that the
light is diffused and diffused light
isn't possible on the moon you need an
atmosphere to scatter the light so if
it's not the atmosphere what is it he
moves closer to the light swan sees
something that looks like an airfield he
describes large structures like hangars
roads towers and machinery across
craters and chasms there are bridges
evidence of a lot of activity industrial
activity cut into the rocks are
perfectly round holes like they were dug
with large earth-moving equipment he
moves to a different location and sees
some structures emitting light of all
different colors swan goes in for a
closer look the domes have windows and
even though the area was dark he could
see a fine mist inside the structures
and that same eerie green glow swab
moves closer he goes right up to the
windows inside he describes humanoid
figures that look almost like us he
describes this as an area of high
activity whoever or whatever these
beings are they're very busy and swan
continues to observe describing
everything he sees
suddenly two of the beings then three
then a dozen then more they just stop
they turn to the window where swann has
projected himself this makes swan very
nervous he says they see me then calmly
but urgently axelrod says come back come
back now swan says they're pointing at
me axelrod tells swan firmly please come
back quickly away from that place swan
wills his consciousness back and slowly
opens his eyes finally he turns to
axelrod and says
you already know they're psychic don't
you
axelrod takes a deep breath and says the
experiment is over it's time for you to
go home
[Music]
neil and buzz were on the lunar surface
neal switched to the the medical channel
and spoke directly with the chief
medical officer saying they're here
they're parked on the side of the crater
they're watching them
though ingo swan's moon experiment was
over mr axelrod and the secret
organization wasn't quite finished with
him about six months after leaving
washington dc
swan was in a supermarket while doing
some grocery shopping he spotted a
stunning woman he describes her as one
of the most beautiful women he'd ever
seen what was she wearing
don't be creepy hello i'm asking for
science
well swann says she was barely wearing
anything at all short shorts bikini top
and the tallest high heels he'd ever
seen heels tulle bikini small she said
she'd like the ocean excuse me hello
cool j i'm going back to cali
i don't think so
nice anyway swan was obviously very
taken with this woman because the
chapter in his book it's barely safe for
work he says when he saw her he felt a
wave of electricity going through him
and felt tingling all over his body
suddenly he felt the hair on the back of
his neck stand up and in that moment he
had the distinct feeling that she was an
extraterrestrial now swan was very aware
of how ridiculous this sounded and he
was about to chalk it up to him simply
being smitten at the side of her
but then he turned around and saw the
twins from the moon experiment
so he panics and runs out of the store
but later that evening he receives a
phone call he's told to fly to new york
immediately and be in grand central
station the next morning and wait for
contact
of course he goes when he gets to grand
central he sees one of the twins
standing near a pay phone he gestures
his swan to come over the phone rings
it's mr axelrod axelrod
asks all kinds of questions about his
interaction with the woman and swann
relays the story at first axelrod is
suspicious he demands to know if he
knows her if she saw him if she might be
following him aswan doesn't understand
any of this and he starts to become
frightened tells axelrod he's never seen
her before and has never had any contact
with her now finally axelryde tells swan
just stay away from her swan asks who
she is axelrod says all you need to know
is that she's very dangerous swan says
he understands and they chat for a while
and axelrod asks him how his remote
viewing success rate is doing juan says
he's almost 65 percent accurate but not
quite there so axelrod says when you get
to 65 percent write the number 65 on a
note on your desk and leave it there
tell no one we'll be in touch and just
like that axelrod hangs up angel swan
doesn't hear from axelrod for a year but
he finally gets his remote viewing
success rate to 65 percent
just as he was instructed he writes the
number on a slip of paper and places it
on his desk and goes home for the night
now even though his office is locked and
nobody knows the code when he gets in
the following morning the note is gone
and on his desk is what looks like a
light dusting of powder and in the
powder someone scribbled two words
expect contact a few days after ingo
swan was told to expect contact he was
heading to the university cafeteria when
mr axelrod appeared axelrod walked right
up to ingo's swan shook his hand and
asked if he could get away for three or
four days juan said sure and asked where
they were going axelrod smiled at him
and asked
have you ever seen a ufo holy [__]
the private jet landed a few hours later
ingo swam wasn't told where they were
but they had been flying due north for
hours so he assumed this was alaska it
was the middle of the night and very
dark and desolate mr axelrod the twins
and ingo swan then climbed into an
unmarked van zwam was given a
thermalized jumpsuit and asked to remove
everything metal they drove two hours
through winding mountain roads before
stopping under a group of pine trees
axelrod said that it's very important
that we're as quiet as possible it's a
45 minute hike to their destination and
they can't talk or make any noise
whatsoever
swan nodded in agreement and they
ventured out into the wilderness the
twins were wearing what swan thought to
be night vision goggles because he could
barely see a few feet in front of him in
fact during some parts of the hike he
had to be led by the arms so he wouldn't
fall into a creek or a hole or stumble
over unsteady ground they finally
arrived at the edge of a lake and swann
asked what he was supposed to do axelrod
whispered that he should just observe
and observe in complete silence and also
to be as still as possible axelrod said
they detect heat noise and motion like
mad swan's eyes went wide and he mouthed
the word they
axelrod just brought his finger to his
lips as if to say
so the four men sat in silence for a
long while until one of the twins made
some kind of hand gesture axelrod said
it's begun at first swan didn't see
anything just a fog coming off the lake
but slowly the fog began to change
swan said the fog was emitting light at
first neon blue which slowly changed
what he called angry purple
the fog started getting thicker and
thicker and then up from the lake a
triangle-shaped craft emerged it was
about 90 feet wide and emitted a pulsing
hum suddenly beams of light were
shooting from the craft hitting
different locations around the area one
of the twins whispers shouted we have to
move so they did then a beam of energy
hit the area where the men were and swan
remembers hearing a loud crack like
lightning and swan was so stunned he
couldn't move he had to actually be
dragged from the area and swan looked
over his shoulder and saw water from the
lake somehow being pulled into the craft
he described it as a reverse waterfall
on the drive back everyone was
completely silent swan just stared out
the window trying to absorb everything
he just saw piece it together when the
van arrived at the airport the sun was
starting to come up swan said i finally
know what's going on axelrod said go on
swan said confidently this was an
unmanned drone an axelrod like always
never confirmed or rejected swan's ideas
he simply asked juan to continue swan
said it's a resupply mission they're
mining the moon and they need our water
axelrod smiled at this he didn't agree
but he didn't disagree either axelrod
shook swan's hand thanked him and
gestured toward a waiting plane ingo
swam would be flying back alone and he
never saw axelrod or the twins ever
again
[Music]
ingo swan kept his word and didn't speak
of any of these events for years he
eventually published a full account of
the story in his book penetration which
i'll link below it's a great book ingo
swan tells a story with a lot of flair
so if you're interested in stories like
this it's a must read
but oh here we go but how much of the
story is true
i i i know but we have to do it yeah
yeah i know so let's break down
ingoswan's story into its parts and see
if we can figure out what really
happened we've got the jupiter mission
the moon mission the extraterrestrial
woman and the ufo encounter so let's
start with the woman in the supermarket
ingo swan felt this woman was an alien
he thought that maybe an alien or
android made to look like an attractive
woman was following him now this was the
chapter that was most difficult for me
to believe
i think he saw the woman but she was
probably human he was under surveillance
by the twins who we now know to be cia
operatives i think the most logical
explanation is that she was a soviet spy
yeah i think so this was the 1970s and
during this time the united states and
soviet union were in the middle of what
you might call a psychic arms race we
know this from cia records we also know
that the u.s was full of soviet spies
next the ufo encounter this was another
tough one for me it was just a very tidy
story mr axelrod knew exactly where it
would appear how it operated what it
would be doing i mean if he wanted swan
to confirm something about the craft i
think he could have done that remotely i
mean if ingo swan could put his
consciousness on jupiter he could
certainly go to alaska and in his book
swan describes light rays shooting from
the ufo that actually destroyed pine
trees and even killed animals i think
this is something that could be
confirmed pretty easily but there's no
follow-up on it now as for jupiter
subsequent observations and probes to
the planet confirmed a lot of what ingo
swan said and his discovery of jupiter's
rings is really a compelling story we'd
never seen those before and they were
confirmed by voyager in 1979 and
photographed by the new horizons mission
in 2007 finally the move this is where
things get really strange the cia had
remote viewers projecting to jupiter
mars and the moon even though the remote
viewers reports were highly classified
they're not any longer and their reports
are remarkably similar the problem with
the moon is that us government simply
will not allow us to confirm the details
there are reports of astronauts hearing
signals coming from the moon but those
signals are dismissed as interference we
have pictures of what look like huge
structures on the moon but the pictures
are fuzzy and can easily be refuted by
skeptics as rock formations what about
pictures of the far side of the moon
well nasa has plenty of those but
they're very stingy with what they
release to the public and if nasa won't
tell us what's happening up there we're
going to fill in the blanks ourselves
it's an indisputable fact that ingo swam
was part of secret government
experiments for years if you search the
cia website there are hundreds of
documents that confirm this and everyone
who worked with ingo swan 100 believed
he was telling the truth about
everything he saw a swan admitted that
he got things wrong plenty of times and
was always reluctant to remote view
places that couldn't be confirmed so i
don't think he's a liar or a fraud or a
hoaxer but did he really see the things
he described
only you can answer that if you don't
believe in remote viewing then the
answer is easy no none of this could be
real these are just stories created by
someone with an incredible imagination
but if you do believe in remote viewing
as the us government certainly does then
ingo swan might have revealed the most
important discovery of humankind that we
are not alone the best stories are the
ones that make you re-evaluate
everything you've been taught to make
you question every truth you've come to
believe the story of ingo swan is one of
these after researching ingo swan i'm
left with more questions than answers
but if enough of us keep asking these
questions
one day maybe hundreds of years from now
or maybe tomorrow we'll finally learn
the truth and the truth whether
fantastic or mundane
that's all we want
[Music]
thanks so much for hanging out with me
today my name is aj that's hecklefish
this has been the y-files if you had fun
or learned anything do me a favor and
like subscribe comment and share that
stuff really helps the channel and
special thanks to patrons jim h daniel
mauricio ew grant stella sal dalton and
everybody who makes this channel
possible you guys are the best until
next time be safe be kind and know that
you
are appreciated
[Music]
do
you